[Music]
[Applause]
uh is Sharif Abdul Rahim oh let me give
you the official introduction the
president of the NBA G League uh former
associate vice president of operations
with the NBA played 12 seasons in the
NBA former Kings assistant GM assistant
coach and I got to do I think most of
the highlights of your career on
SportsCenter because it was never Abdul
Rahim it was Sharif Abdul Rahim and uh
had a great career there good to talk to
you how are you Sharif
uh you might be on mute
I am doing well there you go there you
go you know once a week you you do that
on Zoom so one one of the features but
I'm doing well man
um how about you I'm doing great uh how
about your Sacramento Kings did you take
uh any pride in them making the uh the
playoffs this year it's really cool you
know I was
um
I guess I was on that team that last
made the made the playoffs who lost to
San Antonio at six and
um Sacramento is a great town great
great fans great people uh they they
deserve to have a good team it was one
of the really
fun places that that I lived and played
with you know my family lived there
probably almost 12 years so I'm I'm just
ecstatic you know ownership has has done
so well so well there in you know
keeping the team there investing in the
team investing in the city so it's just
I mean it's a great I think it's a great
NBA story this year
um you know how they the season they've
had they started pass and been able to
keep it going
um yeah I'm really I'm really excited
and I I think unlike a lot of people I
think that
they can get in the playoffs and like
actually make some noise like I think
they're not going to be pushovers well
they can score they can't play any
defense yeah but I don't know how many
teams are playing defense well the
Lakers are playing some pretty good
defense
the Lakers get I mean I mean you see
what LeBron is doing like it's a mate
like the game he had I just I caught the
clips during our our first round game in
the G league and it's like amazing at
you know 38 39 40 whatever it is what
he's doing is is unbelievable so
um it should be fun
um the Lakers are going to be tough but
again I I I I think the kings are a
great story this year all right you
played against early LeBron
late Michael Prime Kobe
yeah um Kobe saying draft same here uh
Michael older obviously and then early
years as well what did you okay let's
start with LeBron you first saw him your
thought was what it's not possible that
he's 18 years old
there's no way he's 18 years old he's a
girl like I mean at 18 he was like you
know six eight two fifty like it's
impossible
um so just you know good you know kind
of if you were building a basketball
player you know I think people had said
like if you built a basketball player be
this guy like if you don't build a
basketball player be LeBron you know
that's you know just first thoughts uh
Kobe when you first met him
well you know is I've known Kobe since
we were 16 17 years old so you know you
you know it wasn't you know like Kobe
you know uh he went from being like
jelly beans his dad played in the NBA
son to like you know his own deal and um
um you know always you know talented
always you know like focused but you
know he turned into you know something
you know iconic and you know probably
top you know whatever player of all time
um
yeah you got a story about Kobe I mean
since you guys my best story of Kobe is
and it's like a I think a really
innocent story is like being you know
I'm a year older so being you know 18
and probably 16 and 17 and being at ABCD
camp and um and Teaneck and and um you
know at that time was on cell phones and
the way you like talk to your parents
was like waiting online at the Payphone
and
um I could remember like I had a good
day at Camp he had a great day at camp
and him being ahead of me online and him
talking to his parents it had to be you
know Jelly Bean and Pam and him telling
him you know stuff he was doing a dunk
on the guy and everything that day and
him telling them this and I'm like I'm
behind him like man come on man get off
the floor I gotta no I want to call my
mom right and um like that's the you
know again like that's like the most
innocent story that's the best Story I
mean all the you know
um you know getting winners and trash
talk you can buy Great Performances you
know it's a bunch of those but those
that's the one that kind of sticks with
me because it was like it was you know I
had a great day at Camp I want to go
tell my Dad yeah and then you listen to
Kobe's great day at camp and it that's
why the phone call has taken so long
like he you know he's gonna tell
everything that he did in Camp we're
talking to uh Sharif Abdul Rahim
um you then you got Mike at the end of
his career
yeah I just I mean Mike was in the Bulls
it was like just Precision you know it
was like like clockwork everything with
him so for me at that point I didn't see
you know progression or early days I
didn't see the growth but I just caught
him it was like you know this is you can
see him like turn on the clock and you
know when it was time to go he went and
um he was I mean he was just a monster
like you know you called I caught where
I caught him it was like
you know four foot Championship already
and you know when they came to town it
was like the Beatles and you know they
mess around with you for a couple of
quarters you know really like make you
think you had a chance at some point you
know like feel called the time out and
you know it's like okay for like nine
minutes it was like okay now it's over
whatever I did but but I also I also
called him I played against him later
when he came back in Washington and he
was still you know great but probably a
little more vulnerable then and you know
you you had a chance then you had a
chance like you had a chance against him
then
um but you know I Chicago Michael is
what I remember you're uh president of
the NBA G League does the G League
recruit
can you recruit high school players
well we we do I would say educate you
know we have the options for
um the G League ignite team you know
past years we guys like Jalen green was
with us and Jonathan thank you
um this year School Henderson
um is you know one of one of our guys
playing in the G league with us and
he'll you know he'll go on and be
drafted this year so I I'd say we we
probably more educate than recruit and
it's you know just an option that we
wanted to provide for really top high
school players you're not saying top
players around the world you know this
year we have a Young Man City sister
called from France we have
um London um London Johnson who had
International background
um Barbara carcini from Senegal so it's
become a world team but I'd say Dan
probably more we educate them and just
try to share the option that we have as
a place for for young kids to develop
well what's the benefit of going to the
G League over let's say LeBron's son
G League or one year in college what
would you recommend yeah I mean I think
it's individual I think it's personal I
think it's you know where the focus of
the young man the the guys that have
come to the g-link what I picked up is
in their mind they're professionals they
want to you know kind of live a
professional life focus on
um developing and preparing for the NBA
we still you know we still provide them
a scholarship or tuition to college and
they start taking subclasses but the
main focus is like integrated into the
NBA and NBA Live they play the full
g-week season so you know
um you know Stuart Henderson this year
he he lined up against you know Ty Ty
Washington from you know the Rockets who
would be on assignment or Kennedy
Chandler from Memphis so he's actually
playing against you know Chris Dunn he's
playing against you know NBA players so
you get that you know you get that
experience whereas you know he goes in
next year obviously it's a learning
curve but
um you know he's had those experiences
already in playing against the president
but you spent one year at Cal but could
you have come out of high school and
gone right to the NBA it's so different
like Garnett did it or high school years
same high school class
um Kevin was and
you know we just it was just so far away
at that time Dan you know like I I never
you know in high school I didn't play
against NBA players I want to play
against a few college players and other
high school players
um you know you didn't see all the games
I just think the proximity now makes the
the kids feel as though they're right
there and they can do it they play
pickup in the summer and they like know
these guys
um I I just for me maturity wise
mentally I didn't think I could make the
jump whereas like when I saw Kevin dude
I was like oh like you know I just
played again like maybe I could have
um but it was just so you know the
proximity wasn't there it didn't feel
this close you weren't as connected to
it uh but I mean these guys now I mean
you know all the training and you know
playing against other NBA guys like they
can you know Rod Strickland was the one
I was I was doubtful of playing them in
a complete daily season when we first
started and Rod Strickland you know he
was with us at the time he's going on
now to be the head coach at La Brooklyn
and he said to me like no he's like they
could do it you know he's like they're
good enough and you know he was he was
right how surprised were you that the
NBA is gonna you know keep the one and
done that uh I I thought that we were
moving towards letting you know these
guys come out of high school and go
right to the NBA yeah you know like when
you yeah I mean I've been a part of it
now on both sides like being a player
and
um you know now working at the league
office you know those things are a lot
of times when we have these
conversations it's
um it's fluid right and you know you get
into it and you know sometimes you come
out of come out in a different place I
think I think also from from one thing
that's interesting when we first started
talking about
um ending one and done or you know
changing the age limit that
uh the landscape is totally different
right like at the time you didn't have
the nil you didn't have the transfer
portal I think a lot of the movement was
like okay it's fair for young kids you
didn't have a g League that a lot of I
think a lot of a lot of it was like it's
fair that young kids should be able to
go earn a living I think you can you
know you see it now with some of the
college kids going back to school so I'm
coming to G League they have those
options so maybe it's not the same you
know uh momentum as it was in the
beginning
did you ever see a Grizzly when you were
in Vancouver I never saw a group yeah
that's a good question I like the
uniforms though
the Vancouver Grizzlies yeah you know I
tell people and they become really
popular like those pillars we hated the
children like we hated we hated the um
the the ones that are really popular
there are like that till we didn't like
wearing those uh maybe my second or
third year they made us like an
alternate road it was a black one that
said Vancouver and we we always asked
like pack the pactos and our equipment
guy he's like well they make me you know
you got to wear these two ones so many
times and we're like okay don't you know
when we go to New York when we go play
in the garden we don't want to wear
those put on yeah well it's like where
it was the Hornets had teal like teal
became a big color there for a while
yeah look I mean somebody whoever was
like doing the marketing Brandon had it
right because it's like I see people
they they sell like crazy even still so
well we always loved the the throwback
the Retro we don't like it in the moment
but then after the fact we look back and
like those are dope man yeah my son he
loves them like he's like man he's like
you got any laying around I was like you
know something like that I said man we
really did not like those beautiful ones
do you have a a big country uh story
foreign
[Music]
having them come to Atlanta where I'm
from and hang out with me
um and like meet my family and you know
where he was from I mean it's like you
know I'm I'm exaggerating but it's like
500 people in his town him coming and
actually being in Atlanta and having fun
and walking around you know like country
he like he like actually dipped like you
know like like you know like tobacco you
like yeah you know regularly and I never
you know I'm I'm from Georgia so I had
like family from you know a more rural
part of Georgia that did it but I never
saw a basketball player dip
um so that was like that was like always
you know interesting me like as soon as
he got off the court he'd go get his
Cane and he like spitting in his hand
I'm like man what do you like what do
you do he wasn't dipping during games
was he okay
great to talk to you Sharif hope you're
doing well and uh congrats on uh the G
League yeah thank you thank you thank
you it's good to see you there Sharif
Abdul Rahim president of the uh g-league